sitting getting his life together
Charlie went out on a national comedy
tour for every night Charlie you walked
onstage you told the audience you were a
warlock from Mars oh maybe you are but
I'll tell you what you're not a comedian
from Earth
Charlie Sheen is to stand up what Larry
Flynt is to standing up
Charlie if you're winning then
something's wrong with the
scoreboard come on man Charlie if you're
winning then this must not be a child
custody hearing
anytime your kids get to see you is in
reruns charlie don't you want to live to
see their first 12 steps
you're the black sheep of a family
responsible for three Mighty Ducks
movies you make your own father a shame
that he shares the same fake name as you
Martin Sheen and Emilio Estevez said
they would have been here tonight but
they had a family obligation